[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: The first thing
is that in this hybrid cloud
transformation, already we have
seen multiple transformations
at the same time.
And that makes it
even more complicated.
The first one is this
notion that applications
are evolving very fast.
We are all used to maybe
monolithic applications, living
inside VMs or iterational
bare metal servers,
running well-established
applications.
But at the same time there
is a new transformation
towards cloud native,
where we started developing
with containers,
with pass frameworks,
using SaaS services
from Google Cloud,
from Salesforce,
from [INAUDIBLE]
and now we have to figure out a
way to put everything together.
And this happens not
on a confined location,
in four walls in a data
center, but now happens
in a world that is
much more difficult.
It happens across multiple
geographies, multiple clouds,
multiple offices,
multiple branches.
And now you have
to figure out a way
how to solve those
problems when you
have very heterogeneous
applications, that they have
to communicate between the
ones that have been there
for 20 years, to the ones that
are being designed right now.
You have a problem
of portability.
As you refresh at the centers,
as you go to different clouds,
as you go to
different substrates,
how do you do that in order
to keep your applications
running with a level of
slate that you require?
And then all this,
combined with the fact
that you have to secure it.
How do you secure it
across multiple locations,
across multiple clouds,
across multiple geographies?
Especially when
you have to think
in terms of
relations, compliance,
data governance, so
it's very complicated.
And here we are talking
about application evolution.
But what about data?
When an application
touches a user that
is connecting to an app
and generates some data,
where do you store the data?
What kind of regulations?
What kind of compliance?
Do you have to forget
about this data?
How do you track it?
So it's quite complicated.
So now what happened
though, is that, as we
were going through this
journey, the infrastructure
has to start changing and
adjusting to this new reality.
And traditionally we
were used to thinking
in terms of compute,
storage, and networking.
We put the substrate
of infrastructure.
We created the most solid
and capable infrastructure
that we can create.
Then we build applications
on top of that,
and we open tickets in order
to adjust the infrastructure
to those applications,
and so on.
So we we're always building
the house by the foundation,
starting by solid principles
of infrastructure.
But that doesn't work anymore.
When I have an application
running in Google Cloud
Europe, another one
on [INAUDIBLE] sphere,
on your data center, on the US.
How do I do that?
How do I start from
the foundation,
if I don't understand what's
the use case that is going
to drive that infrastructure?
So what happened over
the last few years
is that the driving
force of infrastructure
became the application.
So now instead of thinking, how
do I create the best networking
that I can afford?
I start thinking, how do I have
a network infrastructure that
automatically adjusts to
the application needs?
And this starts by having an
[INAUDIBLE] virtualization
substrate that works across
multiple environments, that
now through automation allows
through CI/CD pipelines,
on processes to constantly
create the network that
needs the application.
And then of course,
working across multiple
[INAUDIBLE] multiple locations,
and that enables cloud native.
And we'll talk some of these
things, how they fit together.
The next is even more
difficult, because as we
go through our
application transformation
and different substrates,
private cloud, public cloud.
Now the question is,
who's managing that?
What's the expertise of
the teams managing that?
How do they work together?
So always remember that it's
not just about technology.
Any transformation, especially
one that's as big as the one
that we are living right now,
with a movement of multi cloud
to cloud, and the notion of
cloud native applications,
is how these principles
are available.
Is it dev ops teams?
The IT teams, the
security teams?
How are they going
to work together
in this new environment, that
is much more distributed, much
more decentralized?
So essentially, we need
to figure out a way.
How do we retrain our
organizations, our teams,
in order to work together?
What type of tools
are they going to use?
What processes, how
to adjust processes,
and how to have end
to end visibility
that a problem that happens
in a production environment,
and the dev ops simply
realizes about that, gets
correlated to the
security guys when
a prefix gets applied
in a way that complies
or is always maintained.
Always think, it's not just
the technology transition
is about how do we
bring this technology
movement into our organizations,
and how do we train our teams
to be able to operate on that.
So to that extent, we
started working with Google,
and we're saying, look.
We share this passion
and this energy
to store, saying, how do we
help our customers to drive
the best out of the
infrastructure that they have,
regardless if it's public cloud,
with Google Cloud, or sphere
environments, with
VM technologies?
The thing is, how do you provide
this seamless interaction
between private and public,
in a way that you don't
have to worry about the
complexities of establishing
connectivity?
You have the ability to
essentially create applications
that can move between
private and public,
based on where you
need to have them.
Where is more
efficient to have them?
Or you have the ability
to essentially discover
what assets do you have,
how do you connect them,
how do you track them, how
do you observe them, in a way
that now essentially we provide
some sort of an enterprise
solution that makes
this a reality that
can be a test that's imported
into today's environments.
So this is how we started
the journey working together.
And now we are going to go
through some of the use cases
and problems that we encountered
along the way, and some
of the work we are doing
in order to solve that.
So I'm going to pass it to Ines.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you, Perry
Yeah, so as Perry mentioned,
there is a lot in
common that we have
the pattern of solving some of
the use cases for the customer.
So let me give you a little
bit of perspective of what
we see from Google Cloud.
And what are type of problems
that our customers are
coming with.
So there is obviously a lot of
opportunities for innovation
by consuming Google
Cloud Services.
So in different verticals,
and in different industries,
there are different
uses for how to get
more insight of the data, more
signals, real time visibility
into the data that the
enterprises are generating.
In financial
services we're seeing
a lot of enterprises
that want to have
more bonds, mathematical
algorithms, and models.
We see a lot in retail
and in industrial,
to really transform
their business
by starting to
analyze their data
they're generating
by training machine
learning models, for
example, with the cloud.
We see a lot of health
care opportunities
for providing better
research, and provide
as well better capabilities
for real time interaction,
hospital-in-hospital
communication.
And finally, in industrial
and manufacturing,
there are many use cases for
providing better supply chain
results by getting analytics,
so data warehouse that gets
generated as part
of the supply chain,
being able to
understand the falls,
and improve the quality on
some of those supply chains'
capabilities.
In order to do
that, customers need
to communicate to
Google services.
They need to send some of
the data to Google services.
They need to be able
to ingest the data
and send back results that
are meaningful for those use
cases in real time.
And as it is a simple example
to think about connectivity
to the cloud, we will see
that the complexity associated
of managing and securing that
communication on the underlying
data, that is so important
to the enterprises.
And managing the
services on top of that,
it is really
challenging, and really
a problem that we want
to solve together.
So the first thing that we
encounter when we're actually
are going for these, for
solving these use cases,
is the connectivity
to the cloud.
So we need to make sure
that we simplify, we secure
the connectivity to the cloud.
And in order to do so, we're
partnering with VMware.
VMware is the one by
VeloCloud solution.
So if you can
imagine, you know now,
you have your data center,
tens of data centers.
You have 1,000 of
branches, and then
you really want to
get the advantage
of all those new capabilities
and innovation in the cloud.
You need to start setting
up that connectivity.
For setting up
that connectivity,
and onboard those services,
for your enterprise
and your developers,
and your dev ops to use,
you need to start
setting up VPN.
And then you can think of,
that as an in square problem.
You need to start setting
up connectivity from any
of those branches, any of those
data centers, to your cloud,
and set up point to
point connectivities.
You need to go and
set up your firewalls.
And then you need to configure
those on your branches and data
centers.
Then you need to
go to the cloud,
and understand what
the segmentation is
across-- make sure that
the configuration is
done correctly.
And then you need
to secure the data.
You need to make sure that
the access to the data
is really only accessible
from users and locations that
are authorized to access it.
And you can imagine
now if you actually
have a global
deployment, and then you
need to have geographical
considerations for where
your applications are sitting,
and where your data is sitting.
Now how you access those?
You need to set up
additional policies in order
to enforce those.
So it is very complex
onboard for onboarding.
But I think it is
even more complex
to maintain and operate,
because then you
need to actually have a
mapping of your configurations
in the cloud and in
on prem, and then you
need to be able to operate,
get visibility, and manage that
securely, without
very fragmented view
of the wall in your private
and in your public cloud.
So in order to do that,
we want to do better.
We want to make sure our
enterprise customers have
better ways of doing, and
we think it's possible,
and Perry is going to walk
us through how we're actually
simplifying that journey
and that operation.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
So as Ines was
mentioning, we were
looking at the problem
from the different side.
But we were having customers
coming to us and saying, look,
I want to connect
to Google Cloud.
And I have all these problems.
The VPNs, the firewalls,
that geolocation.
How can we solve that?
And when we started
to talk to Google,
it was kind of a perfect
match, because what
we saw is that the problem
that Google was saying
is how to accelerate
the adoption of Cloud.
And the customers that
we were having saying,
how do I connect to cloud?
We managed to
essentially work together
to create the solution.
And the technology we use is
the NSX SD-WAN by VeloCloud.
it's an SD-WAN technology,
that the way it works
is on the far left, we
have what we call a net.
And this is a managed service
that essentially the only thing
you have to do is, you'll
get one of its appliances.
You're connected
to your location,
connects automatically to your
orchestrator, and that's it.
Now you've go to
the orchestrator,
and you can manage your global
network of all the branches
that you have, as if
it was a single entity.
And in there, you can set global
policies in terms of security,
in terms of connectivity,
in terms of application SLA.
And the SD-WAN solution,
what it does essentially
is constantly monitors
the flow of data traffic
going from the edge,
to any other location.
In this case, going through
what we call a gateway,
a cloud gateway, the
green box in the middle,
or to other edges.
And now it provides
you a central view
of this square
problem that Ines was
mentioning before, end to end.
And then you start
reasoning in terms of,
how do I provide an SLA
policy for a specific app that
needs to be guaranteed
regardless of what it talks to?
How do I provide
the virtual segment
that is going to
essentially regulate
a component of the
traffic that needs
to talk to a critical part of
my applications in the back end,
or it needs to talk
across different branches?
How do I set up
security policies?
But you do it at the
orchestrator level,
without having to worry
about the specifics
of the site, where you
may have to manage that.
Now what we did with
Google, we started
working on how to connect the
SD-WAN technology by VMware
to the Google capabilities.
And we are going to explain
it in the next slide,
but basically you
see that there's
multiple ways to connect the
SD-WAN technology to the cloud.
One is using the gateway
capabilities to VPN,
into native cloud services.
And this is one integration
we've done with Google.
But there's other ways
that we are exploring,
that are much more
efficient in terms
of how to put a brand's
capability inside the cloud
itself, in a way that now you
have a native connectivity
to the VPC, or to the
element that you want
to have in the global cloud.
So with this background,
what we did is
we started working with
Google towards connecting,
as I was mentioning,
all the sites.
Regardless if they
were data centers
finding applications
or branches needing
to connect to the applications
not only to the private cloud,
but to the public cloud.
And by federating with the
Google VPN capabilities,
now we provided a global
build with the NSX
as the one orchestrator,
to essentially manage
the connectivity as a
capability, as a service.
So we went from having
to manage thousands
of VPN points, thousands
of firewall roles,
trying to understand in what
location the closest Google
service would be, to just
a simple tag that you say,
enable GCP connectivity.
And problem solved.
And then of course, you can
go into a more granular way
about defining application
SLAs and security policies.
We are going to see a very
quick demo of this in a second,
but later we can
get into details
and explain you more
about how this works.
So this was one of
the major problems
that Ines was mentioning.
How to connect to the
Google Cloud services
with a single point
of management.
But more important was, cloud
is not in a static thing.
You keep deploying
more applications,
you have your CI/CD
pipelines, you
have your production systems.
You have your PCI
compliance systems.
You have different
environments that
constantly grow in strength.
The nature of cloud
is that you don't
have a set of
predefined IP addresses,
or predefined resources.
What you do is like essentially
you grow and shrink as needed.
You deploy more
environments as needed.
So the [INAUDIBLE],,
the operational aspect,
is essentially where the
significant advantage
towards customers were coming.
It was not just how
to onboard the cloud.
It's how to onboard the cloud,
and constantly maintain it,
as applications were coming
and going, and growing,
and shrinking in the cloud.
So this was the first
part of the collaboration.
And after that, Ines, all
the problems we're solved,
and we could go home, right?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, yeah.
We should all go home.
Yeah, not so fast yet.
There are still
problems to be solved.
So there are, of course,
you know the connectivity.
It is the connectivity
aspect of it,
on onboarding and maintaining,
as Perry was mentioning.
But there are additional use
cases now, as enterprises.
And you guys are totally
familiar with this.
You onboard cloud,
and then you start
deploying applications
and services
where there are opportunities.
But there are reasons
why certain applications
and services need
to remain on prem,
and those will be because
practical reasons.
You know, it is not possible
to re-platform those,
or it could be because of
regulatory reasons, or location
reasons for latency needs,
that those services need
to be localized.
So what we see is
that really, this
creates cross dependencies
of applications
that need to stay on
prem, and then services
that will be onboarded in cloud.
Another example
that is for example,
CI/CD deployments that
happen in cloud, in order
to get advantage
of the flexibility
of those environments.
But you want to deploy the
images to your applications
that are running on premises.
So all this really
creates really, truly,
a mesh of applications that need
to communicate, to be secure,
and to which we need
to really control
the communication,
the authentication,
and we need to get visibility
about the performance
on the way these applications
talk to each other.
So in order to do
that, we have a bigger,
or another big problem, to
solve, which is the ability
to really federate
the communication
and the management
of these services,
in a way that is seamless
across both environments.
And there is a
significant effort
that VMware and us
are driving together,
in which we have a common vision
on how we are going to federate
these services in a way that
can be operated in an easy
way, and a simplified way,
for our enterprise customers.
From Google perspective, if
you just came from the keynote,
you saw that we have announced
Google Cloud's Anthos in GA.
I want to talk a little
bit about what we do,
in terms of modernizing and
building a Cloud Services
Platform at Google.
We obviously have had
a lot of experience
already in Kubernetes
environments.
We have had for years now.
They are Google
Kubernetes engine
on the cloud, which is a managed
platform, in which we actually
solve the problem
for developers.
But we also solve the problem of
the platform operator, in which
we ought to upgrade the node,
we maintain, we are able scale,
we will repair.
So we're really seeing our
value as not only solving
the developer problem, but also
the administrative platform
operator problem, and really
fully give a managed platform
for Kubernetes.
What we have done is we
have expanded to on premises
with GKE On-Prem, and we really
remain with the same values,
value prop, and providing a
managed platform for Kubernetes
in on prem, following the
same principles that we
had in cloud.
And on top of that,
we build value.
And we are providing
control plane capabilities
which go from cluster
registry and management,
being able to
authenticate the cluster,
so that we can actually
manage and operate it.
We provide visibility
with the integration
of the StackDriver with logs.
We are, as well, providing
config management capability,
so that the configuration of the
different services and clusters
can be done from a
centralized place.
We have built, as well,
a marketplace platform,
so that the
Kubernetes application
is not only for ours,
but for third parties can
be onboarded, and
consumed by our customers
in a seamless way.
And finally, and this is
the part in which we're
going to talk more today,
we have an Istio Service
Management that
we are providing,
for managing and operating the
service mix of the services.
And in this specific
area is where
we are collaborating
very closely with VMware
to provide solution of
the operational management
of those services.
I want to just highlight that
really the vision that we have
is built on the open
source capabilities
at these various layers, like
it anchors on the Kubernetes
for orchestrating workloads,
it anchors in Istio
for the service management.
And we really have a common
view of how we can actually
make those open source,
managed value, on both sides,
work together
seamlessly to solve
the problem of the
service management.
And with that I
want to have Perry,
as well, talk more
about how we're actually
federating both environments.
SPEAKER 1: So as
Ines was mentioning,
what we started seeing is
that a lot of our customers
were starting to expand
the footprint where they
would develop those services.
By the foundation of Kubernetes,
we saw great traction
on how to create
microservices, and we
started seeing that because
of the footprint, the agility,
the ability to essentially
sunshade them, grow
them, shrink them,
we started to see
a proliferation of Kubernetes
environments in the enterprise.
Of course, we have the
PKS Kubernetes service
for the VC environments that we
are deploying in data centers.
But we started to see Kubernetes
appearing in the branches.
There are a lot of
retailers looking
on how to modernize
the retail experience,
by putting digital signage,
points of presence,
detection of who's
coming to the store,
and customizing the
behavior of the stores
based on who you are.
So that requires some
lightweight form of compute,
that would be very agile.
So this is where we started
seeing all these Kubernetes
services everywhere.
And now, as Ines was mentioning,
this is a different problem.
Now we are not talking
about connectivity
from the point of view of IP
connectivity application SLAs,
but now we are saying, why these
applications should be talking
to your back end database?
Is this application a
production environment?
Is this a development
environment?
Is this application
connecting to the database
on behalf of a user?
So the problems went
a little bit higher,
where not we were not
talking about connectivity
from networking point of view.
But we started to see
the problems of identity,
the problems of understanding
what applications are doing
on behalf of the users
that they have connected
to the application, what
data elements will you touch?
So as Ines was
saying, we started
to look at this problem
a couple of years ago.
And we were saying,
OK, this is going
to be a new wave of things
that we have to work
with enterprises to solve them.
And we started to work
around the project
of vSphere and Envoy, in a
way to be able to solve that.
But there was this
problem of, OK.
So I have multiple
Kubernetes environments.
I could create what's called
a service mesh, in each
of those environments, where
now we have the ability
to connect a service
to another service,
and understand what
API calls, what
authentication
events, authorization,
all these things.
But it would be confined
to every single location.
And enterprises don't want that.
They want to have, again,
a common way to understand
federated identity,
authentication authorization,
data access.
So we had this gap in between
the multiple Kubernetes
environments.
The service was
running in the cloud,
and we had to figure out how to
solve, and how to bridge that.
So within this, we started
working on this project, NSX
Service Mesh, which is a
product that we are developing,
and now we are in
better state, but we
are going to announce it
soon as fully available.
That essentially was the
ability to essentially control
what we call a data plane inside
the Kubernetes environment,
based on Istio and Envoy,
and be able to control
through the service that we are
creating on top, many of them.
And the idea is that
from this vantage point,
we have the ability to
essentially discover
all the services that are
running in the Kubernetes
environments.
Then, once you discover
them, understand
how are they performing.
What are they doing?
What set of [INAUDIBLE] and be
able to react based on that.
After that, essentially
focus on how to control them.
How to put security policies?
How to put application
level policies?
And getting into
the security aspect
that we are discussing, on
how to have an understanding
of security end to end.
We think this, Google
was working on answers,
and we are saying, well, I
mean we have common goals.
We are all trying to solve
the notion of how enterprises
are going to use services across
clouds in a centralized way,
that now identity, policy,
visibility, observability,
are going to be consistent.
Because at the
end of the day, it
is all about
operations, about how
to keep your applications
running, regardless
of where they are.
So within this
environment, again, we
went back to the drawing board.
And we said, well
Google is providing
Istio and Envoy
based capabilities
in their VK environment.
We are working with our
Kubernetes environments
and providing
standard capabilities.
What if the control planes
that we have developed
would start to federate
between ourselves.
In a way that now, from
a customer experience,
what you have essentially is an
end to an mesh of microservices
talking to each other,
regardless if they
are native in cloud,
in public cloud,
or running on your branches
or your private cloud.
They all form part
of a entwined mesh.
Now of course, that's
easier said than done,
because in reality there's many
more things needed in the sense
that we have to create the
ability to create, manage,
like domains or
global name spaces,
in a way that not all the
services talk to each other.
You're going to have
production applications,
you're going to have
development environments,
sensitive things.
So it's not just a
flat end to end mesh,
but it's what we are
doing with Google,
is bringing the capabilities
on top of the open source
components that
we are developing,
about how to make it
work for enterprises.
How to provide the proper
level of segmentation.
level of visibility.
Essentially the NSX
service mesh control
element, whether it's with
the Anthos controller in a way
that now we can have
a federated identity,
that when a service
on prem talks
to a service in the cloud,
now we maintain the end
to end properties of
that communication,
being able to have essentially
mutually authenticated TLS
sessions, with a proper level
of encryption authentication,
authorization, and so on.
So that was going up the stack.
How to go from the
connectivity plane
that we provide in
the previous example.
And now go one level
above, and start
to get into the notion
of, what are applications
doing, on behalf of whom?
And what data elements
do you touch, end to end,
across multiple clouds?
So that's the nature
of the cooperation.
Of course we are going
through a journey,
and what we started
working on is essentially--
this is the high level
overview of the project.
So we have a Kubernetes
environments,
VMware, PKS on prem,
controlled by service mesh.
And then we have GK clusters
running Kubernetes, and talking
to [INAUDIBLE] native services,
with Anthos controlling this.
And we started
essentially controlling
the interoperability
of services talking
from private to public
cloud, and vise versa,
at the federation level
with end to end authority,
to authenticate
the TLS sessions.
That's the part that
we are demonstrating.
Right now, we are going
to show some little video.
And if you want more
details in the booth later.
But the work doesn't end here.
Of course now, we have to go
to the next level of saying,
sure I could federate identity.
I could federate end
to end encryption.
But what about
coordinating policies?
Because now you're going to
have a set of hierarchies
of policies, organizations,
groups, roles,
and so on, on the cloud.
You're going to have
another one on the on prem.
Now the idea is, how to bring
all these things together?
So take this collaboration
as the starting point
of solving this problem.
Still lots of work to do.
So we'll continue to work as
the project evolves with Google.
But the end goal
essentially is to allow end
to end visibility,
connectivity, security, policy
compliance, between public and
private, at the service level,
understanding from user,
services, and data, end to end.
So with this, maybe let's talk
a little bit about the work
we did together.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
So by the way, we're going
to show a quick demo video.
Please stop by the booth,
really to get more information
and more details.
This is just a quick snapshot.
There is a lot more data that
can be made available to you
there.
Just to quickly set the stage.
I just want to recap
about the challenges
that we're about to demonstrate.
And just to really get a view
of what those challenges are,
just imagine business
transformation
for our retailer, and
you know the journey
that they go through.
They might have checkout
payment, shipment services,
that it's monolithic,
running in on prem.
And then they start moving
some of the capabilities
to cloud for the flexibility,
the pay as you grow,
different capabilities
of the cloud.
So in this case,
they're moving catalog.
So as you are
actually doing that,
then you face the
problem of connectivity.
That's how we started, actually,
discussing in the session.
And you need to make sure that
your branches get connected
to the cloud, and you need
to connect those applications
on top of that.
And now it might be that you're
actually breaking the most
monolithic, that
you have on prem,
and then you start
creating microservices
that are some pieces of the
monolithic that you had before.
So for example, you're
breaking payments on shipments.
But really all
these applications
need to communicate
with each other.
There are dependencies.
There's data that they
need to share, that state,
or there is some
type of communication
that needs to happen.
You still need to have the
communication to the cloud,
and then you add complexity
with the communication
of the applications on top
of it, on prem and in cloud.
And as you go through
the transformation,
you see opportunities
for getting
more insight of your data.
For example, in your
branches, and you'll
see an opportunity
of having data image
recognition in the branches.
And for example,
having ML train models
that you are running
in cloud, in which you
can extract that meaningful
information, real time,
in your branches.
What that requires
is, of course,
the underlying connectivity.
But it also creates
additional dependency,
so your communication of
applications from on services,
and to cloud, and so
on, keeps growing.
You then add
recommendation or you
want to do ad insertion to
add value to your business.
And all that, really
what it creates,
and this is just a sample.
It is a very
complicated relationship
of services that have
dependencies among each other.
So the key is how do
you secure, operate?
How in this environment you
make sure that, for example,
your dev environments are not
talking to your production
environments, that there
is no data that is crossing
boundaries, that is not safe?
The servability and security
of these deployments
is challenging, unless you
have a way of actually having
a single view of these
in a single operation
across all these deployments.
And this is really what we want
to talk about in the video.
So with that, just want
to do a quick show.
SPEAKER 3: A large retailer
operates a global network
of stores and branch offices.
The retailer uses Google
Cloud for the public facing
shopping application, and for
running a secure analytics
platform.
With VMware SD-WAN solution
provides simplified, automated,
and optimized access to
Google Cloud Services,
from every site, over
secure connections.
When a new store location opens,
a VMware SD-WAN Edge appliance
is installed.
With just a few
clicks, the new site
is associated with secure VPN
connections to Google Cloud.
You can enable Google Cloud
Service in the profile section.
Activation is now complete.
With VMware SD-WAN,
customers are
able to automatically connect
branch sites security to GCP
services, avoid manual creation
of VPNs, firewalls, and routing
rules.
And dynamically add new sites
to the secure connection.
The newly connected store
sends real time information,
such as sales and in
inventory updates,
to Google Cloud BigQuery,
for data analytics.
Traffic from
different applications
can be classified and
optimized individually.
Multiple network
links are actively
managed, to ensure that
application traffic achieves
the best performance,
automatically steering traffic
to avoid network issues.
VPC service controls
are set up to protect
the analytics application
from untrusted networks.
If a user on the
public network tries
to access the
secure application,
VBC service controls ensure
that access gets prevented.
StackDriver logs confirm that
access from public networks
is denied.
Now we move on to an application
with microservices services
being manged by
Anthos, and NXS Service
Mesh The company built a new
commerce application that
runs on Kubernetes, and
involves several microservices.
Some services are
deployed on branches.
Other services run on
Anthos in Google Cloud.
Company leverages Istio to
connect, secure, control,
and observe services.
It is NSX Service Mesh for the
services running in a branch,
and managed Istio
component of Anthos
for cloud-based services.
Federation established between
Anthos and NSX Service Mesh
is enabling the use of different
infrastructure, and identity
providers, for each environment.
Services can securely
communicate using mTLS.
Consistent policies can be
apply for access control.
Service Mesh dashboard
demonstrates application
topology, and each services
performance metrics.
Federation between NSX
Service Mesh and Anthos
enables services to interact
securely and transparently
in hybrid clouds.
SPEAKER 1: And as Ines was
saying, this is just a quick,
kind of high level marketing
video, about some of the things
we've done.
But we encourage everybody
to go to the VMware booth,
and maybe to the
Google booths, where
we have live demos
with much more detail,
in terms of how
from an SD-WAN, how
do you onboard board a site,
how to connect to Google,
how do you set the policies, the
applications, SLA, and so on.
And with the NSX Service
Mesh connected to Anthos,
you'll see the same.
How do I discover the
connectivity matrix?
How do I see how
services are performing?
How do I understand the
relations between them
and how to do the end to
end federation with mTLS.
We just wanted to summarize
essentially the two problems
that we've been working
together to solve,
and essentially it's this notion
that when you have hybrid cloud
solutions, it's relatively
well-understood how
to provision services
in the cloud,
how to provision
services on prem,
but those need to
communicate together,
because we don't
have applications
that they don't interact.
We have the payment
systems with the front end,
and things like that.
So the idea was
how to first start
by addressing
secure connectivity
between private cloud
and public cloud,
regardless of how many offices,
many branches, many sites
you may have.
But then the next was
to emphasize this notion
that the world is
moving very fast.
And it's not just about how to
provide secure connectivity,
but how to get into
the fabric of what
the application is doing.
And if we don't
understand, we don't
secure, we don't control
what applications are doing,
what users are doing
with these applications,
and what data elements
are being touched, means
that we don't really have
control and visibility
of infrastructure.
And this is the idea that
we have to get into--
the Service Mesh fabric,
or the business fabric,
of the communications, that
enable us to essentially now
take control at the
behavioral level,
at the SLA level,
at the security
level, of what applications do.
And this is essentially what
drove VMware and Google working
together.
And as a summary, essentially
we were saying, in order
to enable our
customers' enterprises
to essentially achieve a
true hybrid cloud story,
we started by connectivity
and application level QSS.
But essentially, we have to
go to service management,
and understand the end to end.
Because at the end
of the day, this
is just again infrastructure.
And we are not
doing infrastructure
for the sake of
infrastructure, but essentially
to enable enterprises to
innovate, to become more agile,
to become faster, to deliver
new value to their customers.
And this essentially
has to be done
while maintaining the enterprise
class capabilities of being
able to operate it with
the security guarantees,
and the visibility
elements, that
the operational environments
of enterprises may need.
So as a summary, I
wanted to emphasize
what Ines was saying, that
the two companies are working
together, and very committed
to the open source frameworks
that we are using.
We are working a lot
on the public domain,
doing contributions around
Istio, Envoy, Kubernetes,
and some other projects
associated to that.
Because this is kind of a
true community effort that
has the federation elements of
multiple cloud work together,
it has to be built out
of common standards.
And the common
standards right now
are being built out of
open source frameworks.
The [INAUDIBLE] is this
shared vision of saying,
this is not about what's right.
Is it public cloud?
Is it private cloud?
Is it something else?
This phase is gone.
It's not about where
things should go,
but it's how they
should connect together,
how they should be operated
together, how they be secure
together.
Because the whole thing is
about options, alternatives,
and capabilities.
And enabling essentially the
right environment for the right
use case.
And the last sentence is this.
It's always keeping
the enterprise focused,
because this is not about
creating quick prototypes,
or making things run
in a small environment,
but is essentially how to grow
these technologies in order
to make them production
ready for enterprises.
With this I want to
thank all of you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]